THAT IS THE STORY TUESDAY,
MAY 19, 2020.
WE WILL BE BACK TOMORROW NIGHT.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE HAVE A NEWLY RELEASED
DOCUMENT, CLASSIFIED JUST A FEW
HOURS AGO.
IT WAS WRITTEN DURING THE FINAL
FEW MOMENTS, LITERALLY OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION ON
INAUGURATION DAY.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
IT REVEALS WHAT YOU MAY HAVE
SUSPECTED, JIM COMEY DISCOVERED
HIMSELF AS MORE POWERFUL THAN
ANY ELECTED PRESIDENT.
DEFENDING DEMOCRACY AND HE
REJECTED THE MAIN TENANT
INCLUDING HIMSELF COMPLETELY IN
CHARGE.
NO ELECTION NECESSARY.
IT IS THE CHILLING THINGS OF HOW
THINGS WORK IN WASHINGTON.
THE DETAILS JUST AHEAD.
BUT FIRST, THREE YEARS
THE OVER
MEANING THREATS WE SUPPOSEDLY
FACE FROM A RUSSIA, THAT SOMEHOW
HACKED AMERICAN DEMOCRACY DURING
2016 PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
BUT INFILTRATED THE GOVERNMENT
AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
HONOR FORMAL NAVAL OFFICERS LIKE
CARTER PAGE WERE IN FACT SECRET
STOOGES OF VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
THEY WERE WORKING TOWARDS
DIABOLICAL ENDS WITH THE
POLITICAL CONSULTANTS LIKE
ROGER STONE.
IT WAS ALL HIDING IN PLAIN SIGHT
FORGET MEXICO, SAUDI ARABIA OR
MANY OTHER COUNTRIES.
IT WAS RUSSIA MORE THAN ANY
OTHER PLACE THAT THREATENED
AMERICANS SOVEREIGNTY THAT WAS
ACTUALLY IN CONTROL OF FOREIGN
POLICY.
AND THAT IS THE STORY THEY TOLD
US.
NONE OF IT WAS EVER PLAUSIBLE.
IN FACT, IT WAS COMPLETELY
OBSERVED.
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE THAT IT
WAS TRUE.
DAY AFTER TIRESOME DAY AFTER
STUCK AFTER EVERY SINGLE CNN
VIEWER, EVERY PBS VIEWER, EVERY
SUBSCRIBER TO THE NEW YORK "NEW
MAGAZINE" WITH A MATTER OF
RELIGIOUS FATE.
RUSSIA HACKED OUR DEMOCRACY.
IT WAS THEIR MANTRA.
>> A MASSIVE BACK FOR INTO
DEMOCRACY.
MOSCOW’S ATTACK ON AMERICAN
>>>> EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> YOU HAVE REPUBLICAN SILENT
AND SEEMINGLY OKAY WITH THIS
KIND OF ATTACK ON OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> THERE’S NO NO QUESTION THAT
RUSSIA ATTACKED US.
>> ATTACK ON THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR ELECTIONS.
>> ATTACK ON OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> THE FIRST TIME WE HAD OUR
ADVERSARY ATTACKED US THAT WE
HAVE NOT RESPONDED.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE, BRAND
OF SHAME, THEIR SILLY
CREDENTIALS BUT WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO LISTEN TO THEM
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THEY ARE FOOLS READING THEY ARE
STUPID TALKING POINTS AGAIN AND
AGAIN, BUT THEY WERE DOING IT
FOR A REASON.
THE BEAUTY OF THE RUSSIAN FABLE
WAS THESE PEOPLE A RULING CLASS
TO IGNORE THE HUGE NUMBER OF
ACTUAL PROBLEMS THE
UNITED STATES FACE.
AND BECAUSE OF TO SOLVE, THE
DRUG ADDICTION, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OVER TIME.
THE BORDER THAT ESSENTIALLY IS
OPEN, A DISAPPEARING MIDDLE
CLASS, THE CORE OF THE COUNTRY.
THE RISE OF CHINA, AND THEN OF
COURSE IN THE NUMBER OF
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE FOREIGN WARS
THAT SHOULD HAVE ENDED LONG AGO.
FOR THREE YEARS, NOBODY IN
WASHINGTON TALKED ABOUT ANY OF
THIS.
>> IF YOU WONDERED WHY NO ONE
SEEMED TO CARE WHEN YOU’RE
23-YEAR-OLD DIED OF INTERNAL,
THAT MIGHT EVIDENCE YOU ARE
WITH.
SHE ADMITTED THAT SHE DECIDED
THAT MICHAEL FLYNN WAS A RUSSIAN
SPY BECAUSE HE TALKED TOO MUCH
ABOUT CHINA.
THAT IS WHAT RUSSIAN SPIES DO.
BUT DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED IN
THE WIND THOUGHT HE WOULD BE,
PRECISELY BECAUSE HE TALKED
ABOUT ISSUES LIKE THESE, THE
ONES THAT MATTER.
THAT WAS A MASSIVE THREAT.
SO THEY DERAILED TO A LARGE
EXTENT HIS FIRST TERM AGENDA,
USING A HOAX CONCOCTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION HE REPLACED.
WHO BENEFITED FROM THIS?
THE PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT IT UP BUT
NOBODY BENEFITED MORE THAN THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
LEADERS IN WASHINGTON WASTED
YEARS ACCUSING PEOPLE FOR
WORKING FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN BUT
CHINA GREW MORE POWERFUL, GREW
CLOSER TO REQUIRE REPLACING THE
WORLD
AS A DOMINANT NATION.
BY THE TIME THIS VERSION OF
CORONAVIRUS SPREAD WEST FROM
WUHAN, CHINA WAS CALLING MANY OF
THE SHOTS INTERNATIONALLY.
WE DIDN’T EVEN KNOW IT UNTIL THE
CRISIS HIT.
FOR EXAMPLE THE U.S. HAS GIVEN
FAR MORE MONEY THAN ANY OTHER
NATION TO THE WARD HELP
ORGANIZATION.
STRANGELY, TAIWAN IS NOT A
MEMBER OF THE W.H.O., WHY IS
THAT?
ONE REASON, CHINA DOESN’T WANT
THEM TO BE SO THEY ARE NOT.
CHINA IS EFFECTIVELY IN CONTROL
OF THE W.H.O.
WANT PROOF?
WATCH THE DIRECTOR OF THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION THE MOST
RIDICULOUS CHINESE PROPAGANDA HE
WILL REPEAT AS IF IT IS TRUE
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE.
THAT IS RIGHT.
AS ALWAYS COME IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW WHO IS REALLY IN CHARGE,
WATCH THE LIES THEY TELL.
>> CHINESE GOVERNMENT IS TO BE
CONGRATULATED.
FOR EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES IT
HAS TAKEN TO CONTAIN THE
OUTBREAK.
CHINA IS ACTUALLY SETTING A NEW
STANDARD FOR OUTBREAK AND IT’S
NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
>> Tucker: SO THE NEW
STANDARD, THE FAKE DOCTOR YOU
JUST SAW IS PROMOTING.
IN THE AND CREATED THE WORST
ECONOMIC CALAMITY SINCE THE
GREAT DEPRESSION, THAT CHINA
BENEFITED IMMENSELY FROM.
CHINA MIGHT BE THE ONLY ON THE
GLOBE THAT HAS BECOME STRONGER
IN THE FACE.
NO DOUBT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
IS PLEASED WITH THE PUPPETS OF
THE W.H.O.
LAST NIGHT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES RELEASED A LETTER
TO THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
WARNING THE U.S. WILL SUSPEND
FUNDING PERMANENTLY IF THE
ORGANIZATION DOESN’T REFORM
ITSELF RIGHT AWAY.
AND WEAN ITSELF FROM CHINA.
WE WILL SEE IF THAT HAPPENS.
EITHER WAY THE PROBLEM IS MUCH
BIGGER THAN JUST THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
CHINA’S TENTACLES EXTEND ALMOST
EVERYWHERE IN OUR SOCIETY.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAS
DEEPLY ENMESHED IN THEIR
EDUCATION AND IT’S NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT.
A NUMBER OF UNIVERSITY
PROFESSORS INCLUDING ONE TODAY
ARRESTED FOR SPYING ON BEHALF OF
BEIJING.
LITERALLY SPIES ON CAMPUS.
TENURED SPIES.
TRYING TO HAVE PROFOUND IN
HOLLYWOOD AND PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS WITH ALL LAST YEAR AND
INCORPORATE AMERICA UP AND DOWN
THE CHAIN.
CHINA OWES HUGE AMOUNTS OF
REAL ESTATE IN ONE OF THE
REASONS YOUR KIDS CANNOT AFFORD
TO LIVE IN THE CITY.
ALL OF THIS HAS CHANGED OUR
LIVES IN PROFOUND WAYS, BUT ALL
OF IT HAPPEN WITH VERY LITTLE
PUBLIC NOTICE.
WHY?
THE PEOPLE MAKING IT POSSIBLE
DIDN’T WANT TO ADVERTISE IT.
THEY WERE GETTING RICH FOR IT.
AND EVERY CORPORATE AMERICA
KNOWS THE RULES NOW, AND DON’T
OFFEND BEIJING AND YOU COULD BE
REWARDED.
AHEAD OF THE STREAMING SERVICE
CLIP TO BE CEO OF >> THEY WISH T
WERE HIM.
WASHINGTON HASN’T BEEN IMMUNE TO
THIS EITHER, CHINA INFLUENCES
EVERYWHERE IN THE CAPITAL CITY.
JOE LIEBERMAN LOBBIES FOR CHINA
NOW.
HARD TO BELIEVE.
THE TOP SECURITY OFFICIAL FOR
OBAMA AND THOSE ARE JUST A
COUPLE OF THE VERY FEW WHO
HUNTER BIDEN NEVER BOTHERED TO
DO THAT.
A BITE AND WORKED HARD TO SELL
HIS ACCESS TO POLITICIANS IN
WASHINGTON BECAUSE HIS FATHER
THE VICE PRESIDENT CHIEF AMONG
THEM, TO INVESTORS WHO WERE GETT
RICH IN CHINA.
IT WAS NEVER A SECRET.
MANY PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON KNEW
EXACTLY WHAT HUNTER BIDEN WAS
DOING AND DIDN’T SAY ANYTHING TO
ANYBODY.
WHY?
DIDN’T SEEM WEIRD TO THEM.
WASN’T STRANGE.
SO MANY OTHER WELL CONNECTED
PEOPLE WERE DOING THE SAME THING
THING.
BRINGING OFFICIALS IN WASHINGTON
TO THE CHINESE.
NANCY PELOSI STILL DOESN’T
UNDERSTAND BY ANY OF THIS IS A
BIG DEAL.
SHE HAS SPENT DECADES BOWING TO
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT EVEN AS
SHE ATTACKS THIS COUNTRY AS A
RACIST AND BACKWARD AS SHE DOES
VIRTUALLY EVERY DAY OF THE WEEK.
JUST THE OTHER DAY, SHE
ANNOUNCED NO OTHER CONVERSATION
IS LEGITIMATE.
IT’S ALL A DISTRACTION.
>> LET ME JUST SAY THAT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING ABOUT CHINA
IS INTERESTING.
IT’S AN INTERESTING DIVERSION.
LET’S KEEP OUR FOCUS ON MEETING
THE NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PEOPLE.
OPENING OUR ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: IT’S A DIVERSION.
HOW MANY ANTIBIOTICS DO WE MAKE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC?
ZERO, NONE.
ALL IN CHINA.
WHEN YOU WATCH SOMETHING LIKE
PELOSI’S STATEMENT, A TERRIFYING
THOUGHT CREEPS UP INTO THE BACK
OF YOUR MIND.
IS CHINA NOW TOO STRONG TO
CRITICIZE?
IS THEIR ONLY OPTION TO SUBMIT?
MAYBE, WE WILL FIND OUT.
EVEN NOW, CERTAINLY DOWNSIDES
FOR ANYONE WHO DARE SAY A
NEGATIVE WORD ABOUT BEIJING.
CHINA IS NOW THREATENING TO